Thanks so talk about the process because
I feel like one of the biggest
misunderstandings people have a bit like
how large game sites work is like how
much heads up we have how much time we
have the embargo stuff like who gets to
review them so what what's the past
couple of weeks been like in terms of
like just getting games and then
figuring out how we're going to review
them on time well the first bit is is
like trying more or less to kind of have
a plan about who's gonna do what the
problem is of course that we can only do
so much like we have a plan and then
things come in at one time or something
or something comes much later than we
expect and so the plan gets disrupted so
so but we typically have a good idea of
who knows what games and the good news
is that all of us play lots of different
games so it's rare unless it's something
like a fighting game or something very
specific like a wrestling like WWE or a
sports game or something typically any
of us for example we all played Far Cry
so you know that kind of thing you know
isn't too much of a problem when that
comes in but we more or less had people
earmarked like I sort of knew that we
were gonna you know because you know me
or Randolph Ramsay my boss will talk to
you know the PR people in advance that
are in charge of getting us games and so
you me for example is really good about
giving us some more or less a pretty
good timeline of what wins something's
gonna come and then we can plan around
that and and this year
aside from Call of Duty there wasn't
really any events to go to yeah we got
the games in some cases that means we
get a debug copy for people that don't
know that's basically the final disc but
it runs on a test kit rather than a
retail kit because it hasn't gone
through manufacturing so it doesn't have
all the you know all the copy protection
layers on and stuff but usually like in
the case of Dragon Age which I'm gonna
be playing soon is we just got retail in
advance yeah by where's like here you go
play some enjoy what rage did that three
days later or five days later be
different yeah I know things can be
tough I mean but the good news is most
folks are really good this time of year
about giving us a game in advance
although that's not always the case is
it mark no
it's not always the case I mean
Assassin's Creed rogue was a good
example of that that just sort of didn't
turn up yeah yeah that just wasn't the
same
even as he did Eunice II did to turn up
in advance so you know answer I've quite
a lot of time with that but rogue was
just here it is it sound release day we
went and bought the game and then I went
and just happened through and played as
much as I could and did some side quests
and thing when you sort of I guess what
these games you're a particular story
based game it is always about seeing the
entirety of that story making sure that
you're seeing everything that you think
people would see and do when they play
that game trying to give it as fair
shape and trying to do that you know
with a deadline and all that kind of
stuff can be difficult but and the
interesting case studying with Grant I
thought oh damn because we've got it at
the end of last week yeah and you were
playing it all weekend
yeah I caught the video review on Sunday
so we'd hit the like there embargo for
that review was 3:00 a.m. because they
figured once New Zealand it hits
midnight we'll just do a global embargo
where is like sure that's kind of a is a
slightly different beast in that it is
not a new game yeah effectively you know
this is the same they haven't changed
their story or anything like that
they've put in some new missions but the
core of that game is exactly the same so
I play GTA 5 already all the way through
to em and did a lot nearly 100% today
basically so coming back to this GTA 5
you know slightly different process you
know it's not about getting to the very
end of the game seeing the entire story
because we know that we know what's
happening in that game we know how those
characters work
what's important is figuring out you
know what are the new things here how
well do they work what are you getting
someone that may already own the game
and now want to upgrade to this new
version you know and it's getting that
stuff economy and Rockstar is at least I
mean the embargo they gave is sensible
yeah I mean it would have been nice to
have the game before we got it because
it meant for a lot of crunching over the
weekend yeah but there there are cases
where and people are talking about this
a lot this year and I suspect or at
least hope that maybe publishers will
take a second look at what embargoes are
because sometimes we'll get an embargo
and it's so for people that don't know
an embargo is basically like the
publisher is like okay in exchange for
giving you the game early we're going to
set an embargo meaning that you
we don't want you to post your review
earlier than so in so time and so we
that's that's part of the agreements
like we get the game early post your
review post gameplay talk about it right
when you're allowed to do this stuff
like that professional courtesy kinda
yeah exactly but when you get something
that's like it can go up 9:00 a.m.
Pacific time on Tuesday you know you're
talking about you're talking about nine
hours after the game has been out
already on the East Coast yeah depending
on the game people might have gone and
bought it and finished it before you
your review will ever go up and you know
in some you know will push back against
that stuff but sometimes we can't we
don't necessarily get anywhere here but
the more people pay attention to this
stuff especially when the game then
comes out and ends up being broken
yeah example then that puts us in a
tough position
but like this there's a weird scenario
this week with with some no totalbiscuit
and a couple of others PC gamer said
they didn't get versions of Far Cry 4
and we're suddenly doing like tweeting
that as if almost like I thought I felt
required angry about it because I
thought what you're doing there is
basically sort of blackmailing the
developer to like send you the game
because you're implying that there's
something wrong with it like whether or
not there is or isn't but the
implication though like you didn't get
usually send me again I didn't get it
this time I wonder why that's really
tough you have to be careful because I
mean in the movie industry you'll have
the same thing like there's no advanced
screening that often if most of the time
means that but I've I mean we've been
doing games long enough where I I know
that there there's nothing necessarily
implicit in the same thing engage
actively in movies you know that it's
probably gonna be crap yeah but in the
case of games that's not really the case
so for example we didn't get we didn't
get Lego Batman well in advance we
typically haven't been getting Lego
games in advance for examples so you
know I remember getting Valkyria
Chronicles not at all ya know there are
some games we just have to go out and
buy Bayonetta 2 like a month earlier
that we got here that is like more than
a Mario is what Mario cars we had for
America like so in the UK lightning
thunder KOICA descending the cutouts of
Bayonetta I had for like at least two
and a half
really yeah they they had for that so
they have different embargoes would be
an a so there would be some preview ones
there be some review ones yeah yeah I
just played through the whole thing it
was funny too because I mean at this
point most publishers sort of understand
the Internet's a global thing right
Nintendo will do embargoes where it's
like we have this embargo in Europe and
this embargo and and it can be really
odd because they'll they'll have
embargoes like in Europe like a you know
days if not a week earlier than the US
and they'll say ok you can't do it if a
US reviewer does it but you can put it
up if your UK viewer doesn't but it's
going to the same place yeah the
Internet
Nintendo weird and and then there's of
course you know part of embargoes is
like here's a list of spoilers we don't
want you to put in for yeah which is to
read okay here's a game it's so excited
for you to play it here's a list of all
the spoilers we don't want you to talk
about so we're gonna put it right on
this I so a lot of games will come with
a reviewers guide which promptly gets
shoved somewhere that I never looked at
yeah until I'm done with the game so
especially with something like Dragon
Age yeah where it's like here's a list
of things we don't want you to reveal
it's like but I don't want you to reveal
it to me so I'll play first and then
I'll go back and and and check and see
what those things are and of course even
sometimes then they'll reveal something
that I didn't come across because I
didn't go down that particular story
path or whatever but and with something
like Pokemon Nintendo is really weird
like we'll get sometimes we'll get like
pages of like here are all the Pokemon
you can't mention her in the game you
only mentioned things happen well in the
first three chapters you can only you
know and that and so what we'll actually
do sometimes is then go back and do a
second second thing yeah I'm once the
initial we've done that with a video
review for Pokemon before I remember IGN
did something really funny once in a
Pokemon review where there were just
like big black retirees over everything
they weren't allowed to talk about in
the review and then they just took them
out when that's right when the game was
actually released so it's you know this
stuff can be weird and funny and and
sometimes they get the game they
sometimes they get too
- and it's a game that you you familiar
with and you play a lot and then some
weird online jiggery-pokery happens that
like causes the problem like when do we
post this the Halos and crazy halo the
Master Chief collection was a whole
different beast because it combined this
sort of you know oh well I've kind of
played these games before that Marc
experience with gta5 like you didn't
need to play all of GTA 5 - right the
ps4 Xbox one review so I didn't complete
every campaign in the head in the Master
Chief collection and all four halos
before reviewing it but you played it a
lot though I played it a lot and that
was weird because because it was a
digital copy of the game they sent us we
got the campaign first and had those for
most of a week and then they patched in
the multiplayer stuff and then they did
that like 12 hours before the review
embargo lifted which was the Thursday
before the actual game came out and the
server's went live so that's another
question when it comes to reviews is
online can I test online in a like
environment that's reasonable that I
think is gonna approximate the the
reality when this game comes out with
Halo the server's I mean they went on
but they were very scarcely populated so
developers will like organize times like
hey come on by Friday from like three to
six we'll have a bunch of people there
playing but with Halo what they were
doing was custom games indie hiding you
in so you could play the game and you
could like get a feel for playing Halo 2
multiplayer classic or anniversary which
was a trip like Sweden between those two
but like the same time you're playing
custom games and you know you're not
testing the online architecture so for a
game like that what we did this time was
the review in progress sort of an update
talked about the campaigns but then I we
held off on the online multiplayer til
we could see how it went and sometimes
holding off on that is like not a great
move because then you don't have your
complete review you don't have your
review score up when everyone's looking
for it yeah hitting embargoes the thing
we didn't really touch on is really
important for us because that's when
everyone wants to see the game that's
when like the audience comes for it and
if it's not there then you're not you
people aren't come to your site as often
if they don't think you're if you're not
hitting those embargoes so we held it
come Tuesday servers go up then they're
not up I mean anyone who tried to play I
got tweets from people who like went and
bought it at midnight stayed up for four
hours got into like two matches and like
that's brutal and sput you also
understand like oK we've seen it a bunch
of times before online our
infrastructure you know you can't really
test what its gonna be like in the
retail environment to that scale
sometimes stuff happens yeah totally so
you know gave it a couple days and gave
it all last week and held the review
until Saturday but finally it wasn't
like the patches they were administering
we're not fixing it and didn't get
better they actually took away options
on the multiplayer so yeah like you
can't just choose to go in and play Halo
4 multiplayer now
right you could maybe get into a match
as part of a big team battle playlist
but like that's a major thing kind of
sucks
and then it's reflected in their review
and then it responds it in the review
and so that's why the game got a 6 and a
lot of people are outraged because
there's this enduring
fallacy that like and a game I will play
is a 7 or above a 6 or low is a total
garbage pile that you know was created
by masochistic demons that just want for
cutting like that is so wrong and that's
not the way we write our reviews here
like a 6 you're ignoring a 6 just
because of the number you're missing a
lot of store numbers are always tricky
and their ever games games writers will
be talking about numbers and whether
reviews should have numbers whether
stars are better than numbers whether we
should use a number of bananas whether
the number should whether the number
should change over time yeah this is the
Cartwright's burger yeah yeah I mean how
did how to how to take care of games and
how to handle games as they you know you
know change over time I mean we're used
to that in things like say an MMO or
something like Diablo 2 or whatever but
then we have now I mean now and every
game is essentially subject to this and
I think I've been tweeted earlier today
that I that I miss when games were just
released rather than launched because
we're now at a stage where we'll we talk
about things like the halo Master Chief
collection
launch
talking about things like this as
launching like that that kills me but it
so that's why it like when it comes to
reviews everything is just like on a
case-by-case basis and we have to you
know the reviewer has to look and say
you know wins you know yes it's it's
okay to do this but even then we know
that that doesn't mean that you know
maybe when that game goes live this the
the day it goes live that it will be
perfect and that's happened before and
it happened before and sometimes if
we're in the process you know sometimes
that means we just can't evaluate
something and we have to wait at least
two at least attempt but then we have to
draw a line in the sand and it's like
how far do we go before it's like it's
not okay anymore we have to we have to
review this I had a discussion for
example yesterday with with Dan Hynes
and in the Australian office who's
reviewing never alone hmm
because the games just straight out
broken hmm and then of course there's
also another issue which is that he's in
Australia the patches hit at different
times yeah and these are these are just
the sort of things that we have to we
have to work around now in games where
that just never was a thing you know ten
years ago for example and then obviously
like making sure that you understand
where the bribes are coming from who's
paid you off because I think there's so
much like misunderstanding about the
realities of actually doing this I mean
typically all that happens is hey here's
you know we have to plan kind of in
advance when the busy time comes yeah
because we sort of have to know so I do
talk to people at EA and UB and stuff
like that but you know what happens all
that is an email and say somebody's
sending hey we've got Dragon Age coming
to you so-and-so dance like okay cool I
can plan our on that I get an email to
say so we're sending farcry this day and
well I don't know yet about when we're
gonna get cuz a lot of times PR people
don't know yeah like when they're gonna
have access to games and they're they're
kind of you know it's a long chain for
them before it ever comes to us and then
but most of the time it's like oh I got
a game in the mail or hey this games
coming out next week and it's a week
earlier I still don't have it so I'll
shoot you know hey hey when can we
expect to get so and so thing but
Spiegel is just like it comes to me I
know who's available it's like here's
here's your review
for review and and of course now most of
our reviews are done by people by like
contract at all yes that don't open
freelance even in the office it's got
some great freelancers and then but then
that also complicates the question of
once the reviews posted and this is
something that's come up a lot with the
halo review is what happens as the
situation changes like when 343
Industries gets it together and like all
the sudden you can get into a halo match
like that and whatever does the score
change is the review updated and then
how does that change when it's me
in-house versus a freelancer who then
you maybe have to pay them to do another
updated review and their schedule is
full you know so in the case of halo you
know in the case of updating reviews we
have a couple ways to do that one is to
sort of put an editor's note in the text
of the review so people going to read it
in a month will see a different you know
the whole review will be there its
entirety but there'll be an extra note
yeah that kind of done yeah and so we
did that with titanfall earlier this
year which is a review I did we also do
second take reviews and other
prospective reviews though the bandwidth
for that given are the famous one was
the League of Legends one because when
that game first came out it was a it was
a pot of trash it didn't maybe like it
wasn't the game that ended up being so
we have like a four way difficult even
in six refine in house we sort of
differentiate I gave originally League
of Legends to six but that was another
thing because back then we didn't review
free-to-play games yes
specifically as a retail package yeah
but you know even then like we've you
even now like a second take is different
from an updated reviews so an updated
review would be like the League of
Legends review which is like or we did
we've done it with lots of other games
like EVE Online for example is another
one that we did where as second takes is
is really not so much about how much as
the game evolved but like different
person have a different perspective on
this game and we're gonna share it so
for example when Randolph did Disney
infinity and it was like this is you
know I played it as a game I play with
my kids know I have a different I have a
different perspective than then Kevin
and also Kevin is wrong a lot of balls
to juggle yeah but yeah I mean it's and
and people will sometimes ask alko no
video review where how mean this review
came then or
you know this review got posted before
this one are you saying this stupid game
I've never heard of is more important
than major bla bla bla it's like it's I
mean it's it's work right like it like
we it's it's a lot more complicated than
just I decide that this game is more
important than this game you know when
you have you know a certain number of
people you know you have certain
resources you have you know there's lots
of stuff involved like when we get the
game do I have to send it to somebody
off-site we run into situations like
okay so I have somebody pegged to do WWE
is a great example like I have somebody
pegged to do this review that's off site
because I don't really have anybody
in-house and so that I I have an author
that can do it justice and he only has a
PlayStation 4 so even though we might
ask for PlayStation 4 copy we get Xbox
one yeah and so that seems like such a
and then the ps4 would arrive and
there's a cs4 one arrived but we me I
knew provided to the video team needs
footage so now I'm playing WWE in my
evenings to get the footage for when we
record the video and then it comes
Friday night so that's not you know yeah
if I overnight it you know it doesn't
necessarily give the author as much time
as so these are the kinds of things that
happen this is just one game like these
kinds of things can happen with all you
know lots of games in a week and it's
just it's just a juggling act so when
you don't see a review or when you see
this review post before this review or
when like one thing has a video
interview one thing doesn't it's just
that this is all this stuff all kind of
combined into one pot and it's it's a
lot and if you guys I mean if you have
questions about I've been answering a
lot of questions on Twitter about my
halo review and if you guys have these
questions like reach out to us we're on
social media for a reason like you know
at the our bylines in every review is a
link to our profile on GameSpot and so
you can send those messages that way so
this is stuff that we try we try to be
transparent about you know writing about
the circumstances of the review within
the review itself is like not you know
we deserve a byline like at the bottom
of the review so yeah if anything's ever
not clear we're here for you guys yeah
and and it's usually easiest I mean it's
interesting because it's hard for me to
answer messages on GameSpot per se
because eventually like I'll just have
thousands of things in there just
because of the way the messaging system
works in a lot of other stuff
so and and sometimes I'll get stuff on
PSN or Xbox Live and I'm like I can't
really reach I'm not responding this way
ya know like if you you know sending me
an email as easy as always in response
it's there in my byline
it's Kevin via GameSpot calm or on
Twitter where I'm fiddle cup super super
easy to send me a message that way ok
well I'll answer it you know there
there's really no I mean I I you know I
just want to unveil this kind of stuff
like and be as transparent as I can be
if you've got a question just just ask
there's no it was something that we
didn't cover in this exhaustive converse